in this video we'll be looking at how to
deal with a particular kind of question
that comes under the topic of
polynomials we won't be dealing with all
of the theory that undergirds why we
approach the question in this way but
hopefully along the way you'll see why
these steps are going to make sense and
you'll have an idea of how to solve this
kind of question by using a similar
approach so here is the question
P of X is a polynomial of degree greater
than 3
when p.m. X is divided by X minus 3 the
remain is given to us as 1 or when it's
divided by X plus 2 the remainder is
minus 9 so the actual question is what's
the remainder when P of X is divided by
both at the same time X minus 3 times X
plus 2 well my very first step and in
some ways this is the most confusing and
arbitrary of the steps is I'm going to
let our polynomial P be eaten into this
expression now I've gotten in this form
because here is my divisor X minus 3x
plus 2
and here's my question function now I
don't know what the question will be
because actually P could be a whole
variety of different polynomials
depending on the value the Q takes and
then lastly I have ax plus B here on the
end now this is a really important part
this is the actual remainder that we're
trying to find and I'm just going to
highlight the fact that since we're
dividing by a polynomial of degree 2
that's our divisor there therefore the
remainder is going to be a polynomial of
degree 1 you can see there's a 1 I think
that we don't need to write it that's a
really important step if you don't
understand why that is then this whole
series of processes won't make sense now
having set up the question in this way I
want to require my back to the remainder
theorem
something we learn very early in
politics based on the remainder theorem
I can interpret the data given in the
question in this way sits the remainder
when the polynomials divided by X minus
3 is 1 I can make this statement P of 3
is equal to 1 I can find the remainder
when divided by X minus 3 by evaluating
the polynomial at 3 you see 3 is the
zero of X minus 3 it is the same way
when divided by X plus 2 the remainder
is minus 9 so that's where this
statement comes from minus to being the
zero of X plus 2 so P minus 2 is equal
to minus 9 that remaining that they gave
us earlier now the reason why this is
useful is because I can interpret these
equations here based on the form that
I've expressed the polynomial in so for
example for you so P of 3 is equal to 1
well if I take this line and I evaluate
P of 3 so everywhere I see X I'm gonna
sell you a 3 P of 3 is equal to 3 minus
3 3 plus 2 or 3 plus remember what I'm
doing here is everywhere I see an X I'm
gonna replace a bit of 3 so I have 3 a
plus B over on the end to go okay now
you can see what's happening in this
earlier set of terms here because of the
way I phrased it what I'm dividing by
this pipe here simply vanishes because
they're 3 minus 3 is your anything times
0 will be equal to 0 so I can eliminate
this whole part yeah leaving us with pay
for able to 3/8 plus B okay but I know
what the value of P of 3 is is 1 okay so
that means that here I can actually say
this part is equal to 3 a plus B okay
now have you done that first step I
think you can see what I'm going to go
here I was going to make a similar
statement about P of minus 2 by
evaluating this line here with - to my
value for x and the same kind of thing
is going to happen I've got minus 2
minus 3 times minus 2 plus 2 times Q of
minus 2 now on the end here this is the
important part in some quiz I've got
minus 2a plus B by X's interface Bible
is to you now just like before this
whole series of terms vanish is because
myasu plus 2 is equal to 0 so now I've
got minus to a plus BT on the anterior
which I can replace on this left-hand
side just like I did with that first
line ok so that's in place now - all
right yeah hopefully this is starting to
look familiar now what you have here in
is two simultaneous equations in a and B
this is a good sign we've got two
unknown variables and two equations with
which to solve them and so I'm going to
let this equal to 1 and this is there a
problem for us we have salt up to these
equations like this before
and so simply I'm going to in this case
probably the easiest way is to subtract
equation walk 2 from Equation 1 so you
can see Q not pretty with full working
but because it sounds easy equations
these are familiar I think there
shouldn't be too much of a problem for
us what - to the 3a minus negative 2a
will give us at minus EC created here 1
minus negative 9 will give us so they
gives us a value
a that's equal to two and I did now
simply substitute that into whichever
equation I like to find B so I'll choose
equation one substitute a into one that
gives us three times two is six plus B
is equal to one for baby now why are we
finding what a and B were well if you
remember our back up here a and B will
give us the actual values for the
remainder so now having found what they
are equal to we now have our solution
staring us the remainder was a X plus B
but we found a 2 B 2 and B minus 5 so
that means that the remainder we want is
2x and there is a solution